all right guys we got ourselves a final
trailer for The Flash you make sure to
leave a like we gotta get right to it
and also this video we have a sponsor
from a game that I ended up loving more
on them after the video it's dizzy
speedstorm
I love you thank you passing you into Mr
White
damn
wowie
so you're saying you could travel back
in time yep
I can fix things
save people
save my mom
save your parents oh no that is tempting
huh you can also destroy everything yeah
everything I love you too
so how was it this week how's school
Google was good
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die
Pink Floyd
I'm not gonna lose her again
I will help you
[Music]
interesting groups want some help
wait he's Batman God damn right he's
Batman you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
I was cutting edge slang
wow
damn sure so much of Ben Affleck yeah
let's go
oh man
you have fancy friends
the iris yeah I think so he's an Uber oh
exactly
is that Uber black I did buy some
tickets I got tickets everyone went to
early screenings but us hey we gotta
talk about the trailer but first the
word from our sponsor Disney speed storm
now I'm gonna take a moment to be
brutally honest with you guys hearing
about this game and while the concept of
it actually sounded pretty cool a little
bit on the fence as to whether or not it
would actually be good part of the
process that was required was to you
know get some game capture footage of
one of us playing the game I took on the
heavy burden of being the one to play
the game truly a brave and Noble
decision the goal was just to sit down
for 10 minutes here is just the time
stamp of the raw footage I ended up
playing this game for nearly a solid
hour he did yeah John was recording me
the whole time and almost every single
time I was done with a race I was like
one time
just looking at the trailer I already
thought that the game looked really cool
because I immediately got what it was
about you get to play as a variety of
Disney and Pixar characters in awesome
awesome racing levels but it's more than
just a cool concept the game is a
genuine blast now I played An Early
Access version of the game on Steam I
tried a bunch of different characters
like Mulan Meg Jack Sparrow beast and I
got to play through a variety of these
insanely Vivid levels that are just
brought to life in these intricately
fleshed out ways and the characters
dialogue also has this accurate
representation of them power sets and
melee weapons while being involved in
the race make for a truly fun
competitive gameplay one thing that
stood out to me that might seem like an
odd thing to point out was the inclusion
of the drift in the gameplay where it
truly is a necessary part of doing the
races and obstacles as opposed to just
feeling like an added bonus so needless
to say yeah this is a glowing
endorsement for those who stream there
is a streamer mode available which will
replace the licensed Disney music
however when I'm playing in the Disney
music is going off during the races it
makes it feel so much more lived in and
there's some other things we have to
mention to you guys so John why don't
you take it Disney speedstorm is now
available in Early Access for players
who purchase a Founders pack this
includes immediate racer unlocks a large
Grant of tokens which is the in-game
currency as well as golden past credits
you'll get exclusive limited time items
such as racing suits cart liveries
customization parts and more and as a
Founder you get to keep all these
rewards even after the official launch
so during Early Access you can enjoy
both single player and multiplayer mode
leaderboards in-game shop multiplayer
modes include local free play Private
track ranked multiplayer with
leaderboards and regulated multiplayer
where players race head to head on an
even playing field rev your engines and
join the fun like I almost by like I
watched you do visit the Disney
speedstorm by checking out our link
below in the description box and pin
comment and a massive thank you to
Disney Speedster sponsoring this video
because in the game truly was rewarding
any new imagery we get of The Flash I'm
excited for because this film does look
freaking awesome and the word of mouth
in this movie is phenomenal Stephen King
highly recommends this movie apparently
and he is honest when he doesn't like
something very honest so if Stephen
King's got a stamp of approval then you
know it's got to be something good I am
glad this is the final trailer that
being said because they're they're they
are showing quite a lot at this point
and I feel like after the last trailer
it's pretty much able to piece together
how most of this movie is ultimately
gonna go down right up until you get to
that finale it's pretty obvious which
moment in this movie is going to be the
big finale in the desert with the world
engine and all that so it's going to be
a big CGI Fest that I can't wait to go
check out but I really am surprised by
how much Ben Affleck they're actually
leading with this time it seems like
before it was so much Michael Keaton in
this trailer was like Ben Affleck's
trailer yeah there was so much bat Fleck
here and I feel like he's not in the
movie that long so I'm like looking
avoid all of it even though it looks
really cool yeah all of it away uh but
yeah overall I thought this was a really
fun trailer still yeah I mean this might
be just tonally and just imagery wise my
favorite just because it does look both
fun but also a bit intense a bit
emotional and yeah I like that it is the
bat Fleck trailer and it seems like he's
gonna have that one major action scene
on the bike and then a few scenes with
Barry but that was always a part of you
know even the Zack Snyder or Joss Whedon
versions of Justice League that I
enjoyed a lot was Flash uh was Barry and
Bruce that Ben Affleck Bruce so you know
I mean as much as I'm like keep as much
as you can for the movie I was enlivened
by seeing them in that capacity in this
trailer plus some of the Fish Out of
Water stuff like with him having to
tackle his younger self and like
straighten things out it seemed it
communicated a bit more fun than a lot
of the trailers prior to this have at
least in terms of like oh yeah there at
least be some kind of whimsical fish out
of watery stuff yeah it seems like
they're doing everything that we've been
hearing it's this trailer LED with so
much emotion we got to see Iris West we
gotta see uh hear the mom speak a little
bit more as well uh the temptation of
the choice and I'm even trying to
convince Ben Affleck at the beginning I
could save even your parents uh yeah I
think there's a real good debate here
that they are setting up like a good
moral quandary at its Center as well so
this does feel very heartfelt and it
seems like there's so much great humor
and the visuals just continue to be more
and more impressive uh because like it's
weird even when it looks like heavy CGI
to me yeah when I'm like this is so
apparently CGI I still think it looks
gorgeous even when I'm like this doesn't
look real but I still think it looks
great yeah yeah it's really bizarre to
me I I don't often say that normally I
find that that quality uh distracting
but no this was an awesome ass trailer
and I can't wait to see it very very
soon hopefully we can get to another
screen and get you guys a review as soon
as possible but ladies and gentlemen
what did you think about this Flash
trailer leave your thoughts down below
be sure to subscribe uh leave a like
keep a lookout for when we got a review
over here on this channel and hey we
will chat with you all very very soon
thank you to Disney needs more for
sponsoring this video
[Music]